شبح البدانه يطارد الناس فاكثر من نصف
سكان العالم معرضون للاصابه بهذه السمنه
بالفعل ارقام مخيفه مشاهدينا جاءت في
لائحه اطلس البدانه العالميه التابعه
للاتحاد العالمي للسمنه ضمت اكثر البلدان
تضررا بالبدانه ومتذكر كنا بنحكي عن
الكويت
الدوله العربيه الاولى طيب جزيره ناروه
التي تشكل فيها البدانه نحو 60% تتصدر
معدلات البدانه العالميه اما عربيا فتاتي
الكويت كما ذكرنا مشاهدينا في المرتبه
الاولى بمعدل بدانا يبلغ 34% تليها قطر
والسعوديه تباعا الاردن جاء في المركز
الرابع في معدلات البدانه عربيه للامارات
في المركز الخامس فيما ياتي لبنان سادسا
اللبنانيون انا مستغرب من لبنان مع انه
يعني عندهم حميه البحر
المتوسط وبالتالي اكلهم اكثر خضره يعني
احنا متشابس ولحم
زيت الزيتون وكذا ولكن هنا بالمركز
وبعدين بالثقافه ايضا بحبوا يحافظوا على
اللحم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج وال
قصص والاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات